المعتز بالله حسن موجود ايضا في انطاكيا
وواضح ان جهود الانقاذ ما زالت مستمره
ايضا كما نشاهد من خلفك اين وصلت
مستمره وانت تقدمينني قبل دقيقتين على
الهواء وصلتني رساله من احد الاشخاص في
انقره يسهل عن صديق له منذ زلزال خاطفه
مغلق ولا يستطيع الوصول عليه كوني في هذه
المنطقه فهو يسالني ان كان هناك ايه
معلومات يمكن الحصول عليها هذا هو الوضع
ربما في المناطق التي شهدت زلزال في جنوب
تركيا هناك مساحات شاسعه هناك مفقودين
مفقودين كثيرون هناك وفيات كثيره سادع
الكاميرا
تريكم المشهد وانا اكمل الحديث في هذا
المكان كان هناك ليله بناءانهم من عشره
طوابق على الاقل في كل طابق هناك اربعه
شقق لو حسبنا بمجموع وسطي ان في كل عائله
هناك خمسه اشخاص لك ان تتخيلي عدد الذين
كانوا هنا في هذا البناء علما انه بحسب
الفرق التي تعمل هنا لم يكن هناك خروج
كبير للاحياء هي هكذا نعم نحن نفرح مع كل
خروج شخص حي ونفرح كل ما سمعنا صوت سياره
الاسعاف تمر هذا يعني ان هناك شخصا ما على
قيد الحياه تم اخراجه كنا سابقا نخاف كل
ما سمعنا صوت سياره اسعاف لان هناك مريض
وهو بحاجه الى ان يصل الى المشفى لكننا
اليوم نفرح مع سماع كل صوت سياره اسعاف
لان هذا يعني ان هناك شخصا حيا خرج من تحت
الانقاض لكن بمجموع الصوره هناك عدد قتله
كبير الرئيس التركي بنفسه يتحدث عن اكثر
من تسعه عشره الف قتيل
الوزراء والحكومه تتحدث عن ان هناك ربما
امكانيه لزياده هذا العدد بشكل كبير لماذا
هذه الزياده لانه مع وصول المتطوعون
متطوعين والفرق الى اماكن اوسع وخصوصا هنا
في مدينه هاتايا هذه المدينه تاخر الوصول
اليها بسبب تضرر الطرقات بشكل كبير
واليوم كل هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين ترينهم
هناك على هذه التله يحاولون المساعده هم
متطوعون في هذه المنطقه على الاقل بحسب ما
يقول الاشخاص الموجودون هنا لا يوجد فرق
اختصاصيه متدربه بشكل واضح وبالتالي ترين
انهم يعملون على ازاله الاتربه ومحاوله
الوصول الى من هم موجودون تحت الانقاض لكن
الفرق التخصصيه هي تسعى مباشره لحفر ممرات
حيويه هذا ما يقول الاشخاص هنا ولكن سعه
انتشار الدمار في مدينه هاتايا الصوره
المرعبه التي نشرتها الصحافه التركيه
اليوم صورت من مركز قلعه انقره لمركز
مدينه هاتاي المركز في مجموعه مدمر وهو من
وهو ما يشكل صعوبه للوصول الى مركز
المدينه من من لمساعدات الانقاذ وبالتالي
هذه هي الصوره في هاتاي وهي تشبه الى حد
كبير
ما حصل في مدن اخرى مثل كهرمان مراش
وغيرها لكن يبقى لمدينه هاتايا ربما
الاثر او التضرر الاكبر كونها اكثر من
تعلم من شده الزلزال الذي وقع فجر يوم
الاثنين الماضي
[موسيقى]